Yle Areena.
(musiikkia)
Nyt tuli kyllä tupeen ravinat. Kuka keksi nämä vanhojen kiinteistöjen myynnin? Kenelle sattuu? On kyllä niin sinisilimästä porukkaa.
Ei ajatella nokkan pitemmälle ollenkaan. Hallituksen pitää turvata Suomen maata. Nykyään ei tehdä mitään oikein, vaan mennään virran mukana eli tehdään kaikki väärin kaikissa asioissa. Se on kuinka on niin, että kuttumattomat vieraat pannaan kohta lusikatta syö. Heippa rallaan.
Taas sanon tutusti eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan. Tässä jaksossa keskiöön pääsevät esimerkiksi ydinaseet, vessakäyttäytyminen ja autoilu. Toki muutakin on luvassa. Tämän keväisen puolituntisen talonmiehenä toimii Koiviston Lauri. Eräs kansalainen ehdottaa, että Pohjoismaiden tulisi hankkia yhteinen ydinase. Toinen taas kaipaa omaa valuuttaa maahamme.
Ja tarjoutuupa yksisoittaja Kaalimehun mainoskasvoksi. Seuraavaksi on pienen tietokilpailun aika. Tooni 55. Tässä tulee arvoisille Kansanradion kuuntelijoille sunnun tai aivopähki. Mikä valtio on kyseessä? Valtio, joka on Ukrainan sodan alusta median kautta kertonut avoimesti strategisesti tärkeistä asioista. Valtio, jonka pääministeri on useastaan.
sivuuttanut talousasiantuntijoiden laskelmat ja päätelmät. Valtion talouden nykytilasta. Valtio, joka on myynyt valtion omistuksia, muun muassa sähköverkkoa ja tehnyt erittäin huonoja diilejä, muun muassa Kreikan lainat, Uniperit ja Fortumit ja muut. Valtio, jonka maaperällä on ryöstäjä valtion omistamia kiinteistöjä ja tontteja ilman perusta.
kasteellista kontrollia. Valtio, joka on brutaalisesti unostanut ketkä tämän maan hyvinvoinnin perustan ovat rakentaneet eli nykyvanukset, joita nykyään kohdellaan epäinhimillisellä.
Valtio, joka ei näköjään välitä tulevien veronmaksajien henkisestä kehityksestä sallimalla edelleen älykänneen haitalliset sovellukset.
Valtio, joka säästötoimillaan ovjaa vähävaraiset kansalaiset näpistyksiin, varkauksiin, petoksiin ynnä muuta pimeisiin töihin.
Valtio, jonka päättäjät eivät joudu mihinkään vastuuseen tekemisistään päätöksistä ja laista. Esim. liikenne- ja taksiuudistus, oikeuslupa 17-vuotiaalle ja JNP. Ja tällä menolla Ruotsin meno rantautuu varmasti ja se on jo täällä. Se vaan vahvistuu.
Kiitän kaikkia kuulijoita. Erittäin hyvä kanava kertoa asioista. Toivotaan paras. Hei! Valtiota tässä tietokilpailussa haettiin. Jokainen voi pohtia oikeaa vastausta, kun Tony ei sitä tässä meille kertonut. Nyt on aika kuitenkin siirtyä kuuntelemaan pari puhelua hyvin ajankohtaista aiheesta.
Jyrtan vastalauteen sille niille toimille, mitä Suomeen johto on ottanut käyttöön tänne Suomeen, kun pitäisi saada ydinoseita. Se on tuhoisaa Suomen kansalleen ja tuhoisaa Suomeen.
Eli Suomeen ei pidä tulla ydinsäitä? Ei pidä tulla. Miksi ei? No sä näethän sinä tuossa Ukrainan tapaussa. Ukraina oli länsiviimeissä ydinoseita. Mitä siellä tapahtuu? Venäjä taistelee sen puolesta, että Ukraina.
Ei tule ydinoseita ja miten se Suomi jäisi siihen sitten, että tänne tulisi? Hirvittävät ydinosevarastot ja 800 kilometrin päässä Pietari, Kuolaniemimaa. Ei Venäjä kuule siten salli. Ja sehän Suomen tuhuu silloin, kun Venäjä sanoi, että tuhotaan ydinoseita Suomesta. Selvä. Tämä oli selkeä kannanotto, että Suomeen ei ydinoseita. Ei olisi meinata hengissä se virkoja. Minä olen niin vanha, että maan on monta vuotta enää enää, mutta Suomessa on lapsiakin.
Meillä on koko elämä edessä. Antaan itten elä. Kiitos tästä kannanotusta ja hyvää sunnunta jatkoa. Hyvää sunnunta. Papio Turusta, Morjes. Morjes, morjes. Kysymys kuuluu, että onko ydinasevaltio koskaan hyökännyt toista ydinasevaltiota vastaan? Tällä tarkoitan sitä, että Pohjoismaiden tulisi minun mielestäni luoda yhteinen ydinase. Väitän, että Venäjä ei ole syökännyt Ukrainaa.
Jos Ukrainalla olisi ydinase. Ydinasevaltiot sinänsä voivat uhkailla niin kuin Trump nyt tuota Tanskaa uhkailee Kremlin osalta. Eli Pohjoismaille yhteinen ydinase. Kyllä se on se mikä suojaa. Kaikki muu keskustelu vähän niin kuin jaskaa. Miten olet päätynyt, että tämä on se ratkaisu? Ydinasevaltiot. Kaikki sodat, mitkä nykyään on käydään tuota ydinasevaltio hyökkää johonkin valtion, missä ei ole ydinaseita.
Tai sitten kaksi ydinasevaltiota. Semmosta valtiota, joissa ei ole ydinaseita tappela keskenään. Sehän nehän on maailman sivuun tapelleet ja näin tulee varmaan jatkumaan. Mutta jos suojaa halutaan, niin sitten pitää olla oma ydinase. Kiitoksia paljon tästä kannanotusta ja oikein hyvää sunnuntajatkoa. Ja oikein hyvää kevättä sinne. Sitä samaa. Seuraavaksi on luvassa pari puhelupakettia monenlaista aiheista, joissa kommentoidaan viime jaksojen aiheita.
Ennen niistä ensimmäistä yksi sähköposti. Velkajarruunkin soveltuva omaehtoinen ydinpelote. Ei atomihuuru ja Veikko Huovisen ydinaseista käyttämä termi missään olosuhteessa Suomeen. Tuosta kansamme niin sanotut syvät rivit ovat varsin yksimielisiä. Kätevänä ratkaisuna olisi leasing-sopimus Ranskan kanssa. Vuokrataan pari kolme ydinsiiloa, pyydetään ohjuksiin asennettavaksi valmiiksi kolmea.
Ranskan koordinaatit Moskovaan, Pietariin sekä erääseen tiettyyn ökypalatsiin Mustanmeren rannalle. Ellei Ranska kuitenkaan innostuisi, voisi todellista ekonomi-versiota pyytää Kim Jong-unilta Pohjois-Koreasta. Ja tietysti näiden Suomi ohjusten start-nappula sijoitetaan puolustusministerimme yöpöydälle. Näin lukee sähköpostissa, jonka on lähettänyt esimerkki Toisin Naan -ajattelija. Kansanradion sähköpostiosöite on:
kansan.radio@yle.fi. EU, Eetu, Soittelen täällä. Kansanradio, olisi joku mies, puhuttu tähän jäänmurtajakauppoihin Yhdysvalloissa ja totesi, että Suomenhan ei ole tarkoitus myydä sotaa käyviin maihin tämmöisiä tarvikkeita. Ja nämä jääsärkijätkin, vaik ne on meillä siviilikäytössä, niin ne on Yhdysvalloissa ilmeisesti kuitenkin tällaista kriisikalustoa, joka maksetaan armeijahankintabudjetista. Se on heille ikään kuin.
Olisivat voimien käyttöön. Siinä on Trump tehnyt kyllä aikamoisen tempu, kun se meni ehdottamaan Suomelle. Tätä jääsärkiä kauppaa taitaa olla ihan sitä samaa taktiikkaa kuin hänellä on muutkin asiat, että pannaan nyt Euroopan maa toisiaan vastaan, kun Suomi innokkaasti ottaa tietenkin jääsärkijätilauksen vastaan. Totta kai. Mutta mitä sanoo Tanska, jos niitä käytetään nimenomaan Grönlannin valtaukseen? Toisaalta tuntuu vähän kummallinen, että Ruotsi kuitenkin.
Mutta jääsärkien ilmeisesti nyt sitten Etelä Koreasta, et se ei taas naapurimaan laatuun ilmeisestikään sitten luota, kun mennään noin kaukaa hakemaan. Se kaveri, joka otti kantaa tähän, niin sehän oli kyllä osittain aika paljonkin oikeassa, että Yhdysvallat on. Ei ollut silloin kyllä sotaa käyvä maa, kun tämä tilaus tehtiin. Mutta yleisesti ottaen aika arka asia se on, kun ajatellaan sitä, että se tullaan tarvitsemaan jossakin siellä Alaskan Grönlannin.
Kun Suomi nii tekee, niin on siinä pieni riskiriita.
Hänen taloonan kun tehtiin noita pieniä käsileikkauksiaan, niin hän sanoi tuo sinne, että on helpompi olla, kun mulla ei mökillä ollut tuota Masun mökillä ja mulla ei ollut vesi- eikä viemäröintiä siellä ja tällaista. Semmoinen ero siellä. Minun mielestä kun mä sain tutustua siihen työyhteisön kaupungin, työyhteisöön, niin siellä ruotsalainen pitää siis niin sen kaupungin puolia. Ei siellä se sosialidemokratia ole.
Pääasia vaan siellä pidetään siis yhteisön puolia sillä tavalla. Mitä vuosia eletään kun olet ollut Ruotsissa? Tästä on semmoinen parikymmentä vuotta kun mä sain sitten olla siellä. Tosissaan sain tutustua siihen kaupungin touhuun ja muuten ja kävin katsomassakin sitten kun hän oli insinööri siinä kaupungissa, jolla on Oulun korkeudella tämmöinen juttu. Kiitoksia paljon tästä kannatusta. Joo kiitos. Hei.
Terveisiä täältä aamulenkilta. Ihan selkeästi on nyt kansanradioa hankkivekikin kuunnellut, koska mainostetaan hankkipalveluita niillekin joilla ei ole kännykkää tai tietokonetta. Luultavasti useimpikin pankki sitten tähän on herännyt. Työte. Kannattaa kertoa huolensa ääneen. Moi.
Ääniviesti, joka ei lähdetty WhatsApp-sovelluksen kautta. Meille kansanradioon voi lähettää WhatsApp-viestejä sekä tällaisia äänimuotoisia että myös tekstikommentteja. Kansanradion WhatsApp-numero on 044 551 5464.
Nousee sitten näin. Muistelen omassa perheessämme edelleen tulee paperi sinä kaksi vuotta sitten kysyttiin tätä asiaa. Tuli kirjelmä, että haluat siirtyä sähköiseen palveluun. Tiedät, mutta halutessa nyt saa edelleen postitse kotiin. Mielestäni siinä piti laittaa ruksi paperiin, jos halusi näin. Meillä aina on jatkunut, koska halusimme näin, että tiedoksi onko hän saanut.
Tällaisia paperia sitten ei tullut luettua. Kiitoksia Neima. Valittamisesta valittaja. Peilistösi katsoo valittaja.
Veikko täällä. Terve. Terve. Terve. Joku nainen valitti siitä, että nämä yhteisvessat on kusattu pitkin lattioita. Tämä on semmoinen ongelma, kun niissä on pelkät pöntöt. Ja kun semmoinen vanhempi mies tulee sinne tarpeilleen.
Yleensä seisoo siinä vessanpöntön edessä. Ja kun ikä tulee, niin se suihku ei ole enää loppuperässä kovinkaan suuri. Niin ne viimeiset kipat menee sitä lattialle, kun niissä ei ole sitä pisuaaria ollenkaan. Ne on kaikki pönttöjä. Sitten ajattelee, että näissäkin tapauksissa on sitten pakko seisten pissata. No joo. Ja kaikin lisäksi seisoo vähän vanhemmat uppelit siinä pöntön edessä, jos on edes pikkasen syytys sinäänpäin. Elikkä niin, että sinne pöntölle pääsee.
Pönttö olisi osittain edes jalkojen välissä, niin sitten ne viimeiset tipat tippuisivat sinne pönttöön. Nämä pisuaarit olis sitten ratkaisu tähän. No se on katon. Nehän on korkeammalla ja ne on niin lyhyitä, että se on pakko seista siinä edessä. Eli sinulla on nyt ratkaisu tähän? Mä olen katsonut näitä. Tietysti kun joutuu esimerkiksi kauppakeskuksissa käymään vessansa, niin joissakin niissä on vielä miesten ja naisten vessat erikseen, mutta nykyään ne rupeavat olla kaikki semmoinen yhteisvesso.
Mitä on muuten mieltä näistä, kun monesti nykyään on ihan yhteistyössä vessat, niin onko se parannus vai heikennys?
No mitä mä itse käytän, niin tuota mulle se on ihan se ja sama, kun ei niissä kuitenkaan ole mitään jonoja, et tarvitsisi odottaa siitä. Kun se on mennyt tähän näin, niin semmoinen visuaari olisi helpotus ainakin niille, jotka eivät jaksa. Tietysti se on se, että istuu pöntöllä, mutta eihän hän semmoista tee.
Kiitoksia paljon tästä kommentista ja näistä ajatuksista ja hyvää sanotun jatkoa. Niin, joo, tietysti se on se vessan hoitaja tai kiinteistöomistaja, joka sitten vaihtaa nämä, mutta tuskinpa semmoista tekee kun on kerran laitettu, niin siinä on ja sillä siisti. Hyvää päivän jatkoa. Kiitos. Se on hei. - Markku tässä. Hei. Sillä äskeisessä ohjelmassa kun rouva valitti, että pide suikun letkua niin lyhyt, että ei löyty pyljyä tai pesemään. Rouvalle semmoinen neuvo, että kävelee lähimpään.
Rautakauppaan, josta pitemmälle letkun pystyy itse vaihtamaan. Siihen ei tarvita mitään putkimiestä eikä sähkömiestä. Hei!
Hyödyttää vaan Venäjää, ei ketään. Ei ole niin useaa tietysti. Ja trukia. Vasta on nyt tullut muutaman kuukauden päästä nämä kalliit öljykin. Hän nyt nousi viikon päästä siitä, kun se sotat tehdiin. Nää on aika surkeeta toivoa. Nää veljihousu kattelee täältä Euroopasta ja muualta maailmasta, että voi rauheita mitä nyt tehdään. Tuokaaseen presidentti pois sieltä pallinta. Teillä on kyllä velit ja vehkeet sitä varten. Ei tämmöstä voi sietää. Morjes!
Tuolla on pullon korkkidirektiivissä. Tässä on vanhoilla päivillä opetella juomaan kaksinkäsi. Ja sitten siinä on toinenkin kyllä, että kun on juonut kaksinkäsi tarpeesta kauan, niin ei käy enää selityksi, että tuli korkkihukas. Niin muuttuu maailma.
ihmittele, että se ilmanlaatu pahenee, koska niin paljon käydään sotaa ja kun katsoo niitä savupilviä, mustia savupilviä, jotka tulee rodankäynnistä, siis Trumpi ja Putin, jotka näitä sotia käyvät, niin kyllä tässä nyt täytyy sanoa, että jos me esimerkiksi Suomessa portitaan vähän vaikka takka, niin se on jo kuulemma niin kuin valtavasti saastuttavaa. Että tämmöisiä pieniä asioita ne ihmiset tehdään, mutta nuo suuret, jotka tuolla saastuttavat ilmaa, käyvät sotaa.
Niin miksi tästä ilmansaasteesta ei puhuta ollenkaan? Ottaisi mielelläni tästä, että jos joku muukin ottaisi tanta tähän asiaan. Kiitoksia, hei.
Että Norjalla kun öljy perustetaan öljy- ja polttoainajakelun yhtiö pohjoismaisittain, jossa ollaan muut maat osakkaina ja saadaan polttoainajakeluturvatukseen ja jaketukseen, niin jalostus ja sen kehityksen muutkin liittyvät paljon pidemmälle kuin on tähän mennessä ollut.
Sodin sotatoimia ja tämä on vakava vaikutus meidänkin Suomen yhteiskuntaan. Ukraina ja Venäjän asiaa on yksinkertaisesti lopetettavissa, jos se halutaan, mutta kysymys on kaupallisesta periaatteesta ja muusta toiminnasta kuin siitä, että ne saadaan ymmärtää, että toinen voi käyttää sen atomiaaseen, jos se niiksi katsoo. Kuka sitten turvaa meitä ja jos toiset jättävät meitä sivussa yksin niin kuin Ukrainalle tulee käymään, niin ottakaa järki käteihin.
Nyt toimme niin, että siirrymme kotimaan politiikan pariin. Aloitamme teeman Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella lähetyllä tekstillä. Edellisessä ohjelmassa eräs miessoittaja oli kovin huolissaan kommunisteista. Jäin ihmettelemään, mistä tällainen huoli, sillä ensinnäkin Suomen eduskunnassa ei ole yhtään kommunistista puoluetta ja toiseksi edellisessä kannatusmistauksessa eduskunnan ulkopuolella ei ole mitään.
Kansanradioisten puolueiden yhteenlaskettu kannatus oli vain 2,1 prosenttia. Se on niin pieni luku, ettei SKP:llä ole realistista mahdollisuutta päästä seuraavaan eduskuntaan, joten pelko pois ja kukka rintaan. Tämä teksti oli lähetetty Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella. Sen oli kirjoittanut esimerkki Vaaliodottaja kaksituhatta kaksikymmentäseitsemän.
Se, että meillä on omaa valuuttaan, joka voitaisiin devalvoida aina tarvittaessa. Sen takia me olemme niin velkaannuttu. Tertaa vaikka Puolaan. Puolassa on oma valuttausloti. Siellä on rahamääräisesti puolta pienemmät alkat kuin Suomessa ja heidän ulkomaakaapa loistaa. Etemmittä muun muassa on Suomeen kaikki laivan osaatti ja tulevat jäänmurteet ja kaikki muut. Suomi on liian ylpeässä valutassa tässä euroossa. Se on meidät kaatamassa.
Ja ohi virkamies tahon ja lahjoitti rahaa uskonveljien järjestölle, johon itsekin kuuluu aika röyhkiä touhua. Tässä ihmettelee ja kyselee kansalainen. Miksi kansanedustajille ja ministereille nousee palkkaprosenteissa paljon enemmän kuin eläkeläisille ja tavallisille kansalaisille? Esimerkiksi eläkeläisille nousi nyt osalle pieni eläkeläisyys.
Eläkeläisille yhdeksän euroa kuussa, kansanedustajille viis sataa euroa kuussa. Niin tämä perustuu. Kiitos. Heippa Rallan. - Joo Helke täällä. Antti Littmanille kysellisi sitä paljonko Putin antaa rahaa, että viimita tuota atomiasentuloa Suomeen. Eikö sinua yhtään hävetä mielellä, että Sostemi menettää äänet ens kerralla? Ja minä ainakin sanotan Antti, hävää olevan.
Tuhon näkösään olet. Ei ole paljon Soste meillä kun Lipponen pani Suomeen sekas ja tietyllä tie ylättyi, katosi maailmansa ja maailman parrat tiehyllä. Sinä taisi olla yhtä hyvä Putinin mies kuin Lipponenkin oli. Ei muuta kuin Lipponen sai muutamia miljoonia Putinilta. Paljonko sinä saat häpeä? - Me emme halua enää eduskuntaan huuhaa poliitikkoja, jotka eivät tee yhtään mitään.
rahansa eteen, paitsi nostavat palkkojaan ja vielä kehtaavat ottaa eduskuntaan veronmaksajien rahoilla huuhaa avustajia, kun tekevät niin sanotusti kahta työtä. Tää täytyy saada poikki, se on vähän joko tai jos on eduskunnassa niin sitten ei hypitä hyvinvointialueella ja tää täytyy saada lakiin ehdottomasti ja nopeasti.
Olet joko tai hyvinvointialueella tai eduskunnassa. Hei hei. Siinä meidät kuljetettiin hyvinvointialueille eli sote aiheita on luvassa seuraavaksi. Niitä ennen kerron, että Yleisradion satavuotisjuhlavuoden kunniaksi verkkoon on avattu Yle-kauppa. Sieltä voi ostaa yhtiön ohjelmiin liittyviä tuotteita. Kaupan valikoimasta löytyy tällä hetkellä esimerkiksi Kansanradion lokolla varustettavissa tuotteita.
Täällä Joensusta eläisikäihminen vanhustenhoidosta nyt kaavaillaan taas leikattavaksi seuraavalla vaalikaudella kaksista miljoonaa euroa ja tiedän muun muassa pari semmoista ihmistä millä on se tietokoneenäyttö jonka kautta otetaan terveydenhuollosta kotihoitajat yht'että. Mutta sitten kun on hiukan muistisairas esimerkiksi joutuu sairaalaan alkaa.
Ambulanssin kutsuttuaan ja ei muista ilmoittaa siten kotihoidolle että hän on yön taikka pari yön sairaalassa ja tulee kotiin niin sitä koko kone on tiltissä eli missäpä otat lääkkeet kun kone ei ole muistuttamassa että oletko ottanut lääkkeen.
Ongelmia joita mullakin on ja yleensä vanhoilla miehillä on. Mä haluaisin nyt tietää muilta Kansanradion kuuntelijoita saavatko kaikki näitä mainoksia vai kohdistuuko ne vaan niihin joilla on näitä terveydellisiä ongelmia. Ja jos näin on niin mistä he saavat näitten henkilöitten nimet. Se on käsittämätöntä. Siellä on ihmeellisi poppomiehiä ja lääkkeitä myydään monevaivaan ja ne tulee suoraan kotiin. Ja ei voi muuta kuin ihmetellä sitä lupaus.
Miten tulvaa mitä kaikkea ne terveysongelmia poistaa. Ja siellä on nimekkäitä lääkäreitä. Kaikki ne lääkäri jotka näitä markkinoivat ovat hyvin usein mediassa esillä. Ei voi olla täysin perätöntä se heidän tieto. Eli kiinnostaa sosiaalisen median kohdennetut lääkemainokset jo nimenomaan ja niitä ei myydä aptekissa. Ne ovat nimenomaan semmoisia lääkkeitä joita saa ostaa vaan heiltä. Ja minun mielestäni.
- Nyt leikitään aika vakavalla asialla, koska tämmöiset sairaat ihmiset, joihin minäkin kuulun, niin meillä on tietysti epätoivonnan tarve saada jostakin lääkitystä niihin ongelmiin, joita me olemme saaneet ja apua näiltä viralliselta terveydenhoidon puolelta, niin me totta kai kun me huomataan lupauksia paranemisesta tietyille lääkkeille, niin totta kai me yritämme hakea apua sieltäkin. Tämä ongelma on minun mielestäni hyvin vakava, jos nämä vielä ovat täysin perättömiä, että ne eivät anna minkäänlaista terveydestä tunnetta.
niin eihän tällaista mainosta, minun mielestäni oikeusvaltios voi harjoittaa. - Kiitoksia paljon tästä puhelusta ja tästä kannanotusta ja hyvää sunnunta jatkoa. - Joo kiitos. - Haluaisin huomioida niitä heikko-osaisia, joita on viety hallitus, viennyt paljon. He eivät taisi varmaan vastaamaan tänne kansanradioonkaan, koska puhelimet ja kaikki ovat aika kalliita. Toivoisin, että hallitus huomioisi vähän näitä huono-osaisempia.
En tiedä kuinka paljon ihmisiä on tällä hetkellä leipäjonoissa ja muissa kaikissa. Miehni sanoi aikanaan, että sinä et ikinä pysty yksin auttamaan ketään, mutta toivoisin, että herättäisi niin, että ihmiset pääsisivät jotenkin jaloinnensa. Ei muuta kuin nainen porista.
Muistutan, että kansardion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan joka perjantai kello kaksikymmentäyksi. Jos merkkaat sydämen kuvasta ja tilaat ohjelmasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta, niin saat aina ensimmäisenä tiedon, kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Minun mielestäni toi autollu pitäis verottaa sille, että mitä isommassa kaupungissa asuu, sitä enemmän sitä verotetaan. Pensan hinta pitäis olla samanlailla, eli syrjekylillä ja muissa, niin se pensan hinta ois huomattavaa.
Mutta näissä isoissa kaupungeissa, missä on hyvät julkiset linja-autoyhteydet, niihin kaupunkeihin pitäisi pensan hintaa lisätä todella paljon niin kuin tavallaan tämän maaseudun lisäyksen verran. Eli maaseudulla pitäisi olla edullinen pensa tällaisissa paikoissa, missä eivät linja-autot kuija. Ja sitten tällaiset isot kaupungit, niissä olisi myös se maaseudun lisä. Tällä tavalla maaseudullakin voisi sitä autoa paremmin pitää, kun se pensa olisi.
Edullista mielestä tämä pitäisi Suomessa tehdä, ei muuta.
Sinne minne ratista hoidetaan, kun auto menee vain mutaliitoa koko ajan ja liejuveli lentää siinä ja kirjahvi kattoo kaula pitkällä rallia ja apina puissa roikkuja taputtaa, kun tulee suomalainen ja ranskalainen ja englantilainen rallimies kaasuttaa, rapa lentää ja pensaa palaa. Ja siellä ei ole nyt tuota niin vaaraa mistään metsäpaloista, kun on tosiaan tuota vettä tullut niin paljon tuolla Afrikasta, että sinne pitäisi Suomesta saada tietyömiehiä tekemään sitä tietä niitä.
Rallimies, että nii saisi siellä ajaa oikein rallia sydämensä kyljyksestä yllyydestä. Kyllä Suomessa on menekohan hyvä tiet viera, jos verrataan noihin kehitysmaihin, jollei näe niitä pommita kohta monttuja täyteen. Varsinkin siellä itärajalla kannattaa olla tarkkana, että mitä siellä ilmakehässä tapahtuu, että kuka siellä liikkuu. Joo, ei muuta kuin kevään jatkoja.
Kirjoitakaa Kansanradion puhelinnumero. Se on 08 001 5564 ja puhelu on soittaajalle maksuton. Ja muistutuksena, että sunnuntaisin kello 12.30 alkaen tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmisvastaja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Johtuuko tämä siitä syystä, että Ylekin joutuu säästämään? Vai mistä? Eikö tätä saada korjattua? On tosi kiusallista, kun puhe jatkuu ja ihmisen suu on jo kiinni.
Muissa ohjelmissa ollaan joku rumpali takana. Ei saa vanhemmat ihmiset selvää puheesta. Jatketaanpa keskustelua myöhemmin. Hei.
Kyllä Rario 1 on myös koko kansanrario. No niin, täältä soittaa Mestari Myrkky Keski Suomesta. Nyt se taas kerran tapahtui. Nämä paikallisuutiset ja myöskin valtakunnalliset uutiset on mitoitettu sillä tavoin, että ne kestävät ainoastaan kaksi minuuttia melkein joka kerta. Uutisten viimeiset sanat katkeavat poikki. Minusta tämä on ärsyttävää. Elikkä jos itse olisin tuossa.
Uutisten lukijan työssä niin kyllä minun stressitasot ainakin nousisivat. Minun esitykseni on niin, että uutisten lukuajan pitää olla vähintään kolme minuuttia, että kuullaan ne viimeisetkin sanat siitä, mitä uutisten lukija haluaa meille kertoa. Kiitos. Hyvää päivänjatkoa Kansanradioon. Kiitoksia ja tervetuloa ohjelmamme sanataidetuokioon. Aloitamme postikortilla, jossa lukijat ovat.
Oikein näin. Kaksi aforismia, jotka ovat oma keksimiä. Yksi: Jos pidät itseäsi tyhmänä, voit silti elää fiksusti. Kaksi: Täytyy liikkua, vaikka ei jaksaisikaan.
Yleisradio oli meille lähettänyt postikortilla Toivo Kalevi Koijärvi. Kansanradioon voi lähettää kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postiaosoitteeseen Kansanradio pl79 00024 Yleisradio.
Toivottavasti hyvää päivää. Luen runoni pienelle lapselle. Olet lapseni vielä niin pieni, vielä on elämä edessä. Paljon kohtaat elämäsi aikana, monta hetkeä kaunista. Oltas vielä pieni, niin nuori, ees sää elämä alkava, vaan katsopa silmin niin avoimin. Katso mielin niin turvallisin, et yksin oo pienihminen. Olet turvassa, suojelus enkelin, olkoon elos ain turvallisin.
Kirjeistä ainakin on vielä asiaa luvassa. Ennen viimeisiä puheluita minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää. Koiviston Lauri kiittää ja kumartaa Kansanradio jälleen viikon päästä.
No hei tältä kirskonummelta! Olen tosi vihainen, että multa on hävinnyt yhdeksän kirjettä ja meni tuultavasti jonkun toisen postilaatikkoon ja meni roskikselle lehtilaatikon ja siellä ne oli revitty, heitetty roskikseen. Että miten voi olla tällasia naapureita, jotka tekee näin? Onko ne mielipuolisia vai mitä ne yrittää? Mulle eivät siin asumistuki sen takia, että mun kiri ei tullu perälle. Kiitos naapuret!
Ei tää tähä jää! Moikka!
Että lopulta me kaikki päädymme mulanalle kukkien peittelemaksi. Ottakaa kantaa asiaan kuomemassa. Kiitos, hei hei!
On nyt sinä kuka viljelee sitä kaalia Suomessa, tätä valkokaalia. Tuo markkinoilleni kaalimehu ja ota mut siihen nettiinista mainostamasta. Saat näkyvyyttä.